et place au grand débat politique de
cette émission bonjour messieurs merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté ce débat
François Patriat président du groupe
RDPI ici au Sénat c'est le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle soutien
évidemment d'Emmanuel Macron merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Alexis
Corbière bonjour député la France
insoumise de seine-saint-denisport
paroles de Jean-Luc Mélenchon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Stéphane Le
Ruggier sénateur les républicains des
Bouches-du-Rhône bonjour soutien de
Valérie Pécresse et pierrevé Fabre au
bréspi bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes porte-parole de
Marine Le Pen on va commencer par une
question à chacun sur les résultats
François Patriat il y a bien sûr la
victoire hier à 58% mais en même temps
58% c'est 8 points de moins quand en
2017 et il y a aussi une abstention très
élevée un record depuis 1969 je vois que
vous êtes devenus en même temps ça me
fait plaisir moi je le suis depuis pas
mal d'années vous savez un soir comme
hier soir on est partagé entre plusieurs
sentiments d'abord bien sûr la fierté le
bonheur
j'ai eu des échecs et des victoires dans
ma carrière il faut assumer ses défaites
il faut savoir aussi ces victoires un
peu même si je vois bien que déjà ce
matin le répit et peut laisser à la
majorité ensuite je dis gravité gravité
parce que parce que la situation dans ce
pays dans le monde dans l'Europe
aujourd'hui est grave et que il faut
prendre cette élection bien je le dis
avec bonheur mais aussi sans du tout
faire de triompher absolument
patriotique ni arrogance il faut ce soir
c'est dire que comme l'avait dit le
président et il y a quelques semaines
quelques mois le plus dur est devant
nous le plus dur est devant nous vu la
situation internationale vu les drames
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui en Ukraine
et autour la situation économique avec
l'inflation qui reprend aujourd'hui les
problèmes climatiques qui vont survenir
à la suite des désordres qui arrivent en
Europe de l'Est on voit bien que la
situation va être difficile et dans le
même temps en même temps le président
aura à faire des reconduire des réformes
il l'a dit va les conduire avec avec une
méthode nouvelle là il dit lui-même et
je le crois parce que j'en ai parlé avec
lui à plusieurs reprises et avec ses
amis de co-construction de réformes
importantes tout en essayant de redonner
aux Français de l'optimisme qu'ils
avaient perdu et on va parler de cette
méthode vous à votre Fabre au brexit
comment vous l'avez accueilli ce
résultat d'hier est-ce qu'il y a eu la
déception dans le camp de Marine Le Pen
on est toujours un peu de déception
quand on ne gagne pas une élection mais
vous l'avez fait observer le score qu'a
obtenu Marine Le Pen et le plus élevé
qu'elle est obtenue et beaucoup plus
quand 2017 et surtout la victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron est obtenu dans des
conditions très particulières
pratiquement sans faire campagne ou à
partir du 8 mars donc très peu avant le
premier tour
intensément entre les deux tours et ce
n'est pas une un vote d'adhésion c'est à
votre de rejet de l'adversaire on n'a
jamais autant apparent en 2017 jeté
l'anathème sur un candidate deuxième
tour quand on fait la comparaison avec
le débat entre à la Power et Georges
Pompidou en 1969 c'était pas du tout
pareil
c'est fond républicain qui a joué hier
soir c'est pas Marine Le Pen qui a
échoué à convaincre les Français son
programme
et dont il faudra tout dire compte il
faut que ce score se trouve sa
représentation dans les institutions on
en parlera à propos des élections
législatives mais vous aviez l'ensemble
des parties politiques l'ensemble des
médias pratiquement qui appelaient à
voter ou soutenait Emmanuel Macron vous
êtes exactement dans la même situation
que celle qui a conduit en France à
des expressions majoritaires du peuple
français je pense au référendum de 2005
par exemple alors même que tout le monde
prédisait à oui ou de ce qui s'est passé
au Royaume-Uni avec le brexit ou avec
l'élection de Donald Trump je pense je
parle bien entendu de celle de 2016 et
pas celle de façon échec de 2020 et donc
il y a une cassure au sein du peuple
français il faut que les 40% et 41,5%
des Français qui ont voté pour elle soit
représentées il faut aussi tenir compte
de la cassure sociale qu'il y a il y a
une véritable fracture et Marine Le Pen
et tous ceux qui l'entourent et
auront vocation à l'exprimer au moment
des élections législatives
Marine Le Pen aire n'a pas salué la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron dans son
discours contrairement à ce que veut
l'usage républicain ce qu'elle a appelé
le président de la République hier soir
pourquoi elle n'a pas salué sa victoire
de son adversaire on n'a pas besoin de
de le souligner ça saute aux yeux des
Français c'est le premier visage qui
apparaît à 20h et donc il n'y avait pas
de d'ambiguïté là-dessus Corbière
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a pris la parole
très vite après 20h et lui il a beaucoup
insisté sur le fait que Emmanuel Macron
était mal élu qu'il surnageait dans un
océan de bulletins blonde d'abstention
de votre nul est-ce que vous remettez en
côte légitimité politique de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron hier
Emmanuel Macron est élu président de la
République c'est un fait c'est comme ça
les institutions sont ce qu'elles sont
et il est indiscutablement élu ce serait
absurde que de vouloir le remettre en
cause par contre quand on est
républicain qu'on est attaché à la
souveraineté populaire on doit observer
ce qui a eu lieu Emmanuel Macron a gagné
je le répète toutefois il a obtenu 38 %
des électeurs inscrits sur encore
électoral de 48,7 millions de personnes
c'est-à-dire qu'il est minoritaire et
le représentant du rassemblement
national la bien dit il a été élu sur un
rejet de l'adversaire très clairement
une personne sur deux a sans doute a
sans doute voté pour Emmanuel Macron
parce qu'il ne voulait pas l'élection de
Madame Le Pen Madame Le Pen c'était
celle qui pouvait faire élire à nouveau
Emmanuel Macron c'est le meilleur
service qui pourrait être ennuyeux
Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'il soit face à
Madame Le Pen et d'ailleurs
contrairement à ce que vous disiez
beaucoup du débat c'est cinq dernières
années à tourner autour de Vottem parce
que vous étiez mis en valeur on vous a
des diabolisé vous avez été surpris d'un
seul coup d'être rediabolisé tellement
tout se passait bien depuis ces cinq
dernières années et y compris monsieur
Zemmour était un peu apparu quasiment
comme faire valoir mon web je reprends
pas tous ces débats mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est minoritaire deux tiers
des Français n'ont pas voté pour le
président de la Cinquième République qui
va concentrer énormément de pouvoir
est-ce démocratique et bien on a une
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a les
élections de juin pour rediscuter et
nous on va tranquillement
démocratiquement on n'est pas les seuls
je veux dire mais on va mettre cette
affaire là on a observé le premier tour
on dit qu'il y a trois blocs de taille
peut vous pros égales on arrive
troisième je le regrette mais voilà 22%
23% Madame Le Pen pardon 25 26 j'ai
oublié monsieur
28 Emmanuel Macron et puis 12 millions
de gens qui s'absciennent c'est pas rien
regardons les parce qu'en plus c'est
souvent les milieux populaires faut leur
parler quand même parce que c'est un
problème donc si on est d'accord avec la
retraite à 60 ans si on est d'accord
avec comment l'augmentation du SMIC si
on veut le blocage des prix si on veut
des mesures écologiques si on veut en
finir avec ces institutions la Cinquième
République il y a un blog populaire qui
va se constituer autour de nous je
reviendrai peut-être ou d'autres de mes
amis vous en parler dans les jours qui
viennent est-ce qu'on arrive avec
d'autres forces politiques sans
exclusive à créer des conditions d'un
rassemblement à vocation majoritaire et
au mois de juin pour tes Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Premier ministre c'est
possible on va en parler dans quelques
instants ces fan de régulier vous
comment vous avez accueilli ce résultat
d'hier écoutez je pense que le résultat
de l'élection s'impose s'impose à tous
et à nous tous maintenant si on fait un
peu un retour très bref d'expérience de
cette campagne campagne présidentielle
qui a été totalement atrophiée par des
événements extérieurs crise sanitaire
guerre en Ukraine et je pense que la
majorité des Français n'ont pas eu les
réponses à leur préoccupations
quotidienne inflation pouvoir d'achat en
berne crise énergétique avec un coût
d'énergie qui qui explose enfin tout ça
pour dire que effectivement
il n'y a pas de problème de légitimité
du candidat Macron et du président
maintenant Macron mais tout de même
quand on a une abstention aussi forte
quand on a deux tiers des Français qui
ont
voter non pas Emmanuel Macron mais pour
d'autres d'autres personnes faut
s'interroger sur comment mener le
nouveau le nouveau quinquennat et puis
après il y a aussi une problématique
très criante
le débat démocratique a été confisqué je
l'ai dit sur le premier et le deuxième
tour il y a un troisième tour qui
s'appelle l'élection législative et je
pense et j'espère sincèrement que le
débat aura lieu parce que s'il n'a pas
lieu et je le répète on aura une crise
sociale sans précédent dès le début de
du mois de septembre François débat
démocratique confisqué ça vous intéresse
pas vrai président de la République a
été élu avec 42% des inscrits il y a
beaucoup de mer et de près dans le
conseil départementaux régionaux qui ont
été élus avec 10 % des inscrits personne
ne remet en cause aujourd'hui un
deuxième tour les concerts non personne
qui a une personne plus ensuite le Deep
42% des inscrits c'est plus que Pompidou
c'est plus que Jacques Chirac en 95
c'est plus que François Hollande
personne n'a remis en cause
de l'adversaire c'est vrai qu'en France
je vous écoute bien on va essayer de se
ça partait bien on va essayer de se
dégénère pas ensuite on connaît votre
François les élections ce n'était pas
les mêmes mais je sais avec qui je sais
bon alors ensuite ce n'est pas les mêmes
solutions mais à chaque fois en France
vous savez très bien à chaque élection
présidentielle c'est souvent un vote par
défaut en plus parce que jusqu'à Giscard
d'Estaing père parce que parce que les
gens ont votaient contre Giscard
Emmanuel Macron était était le
responsable de tous les trous de la
terrasse c'est pas lui qui est
responsable de l'inflation c'est pas lui
qui est responsable de la hausse du prix
du pétrole 18 gars c'est pas lui non il
est responsable de rien d'ailleurs
Macron est responsable de l'inflation
alors que nous sommes à 4 % d'inflation
et que tous nos voisins sont 7 %
d'inflation c'est parce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui le blocage des déprime qu'il
a fait que c'est très bien voilà
quand j'entends monsieur patriadir
effectivement que c'est à cause des
parties traditionnelles que que les
extrêmes sont en train de monter moi
depuis 5 ans Emmanuel Macron rêvait 2
secondes tout entre Marine Le Pen et
lui-même ça a été ça a été orchestré
maintenant Emmanuel Macron se trompe
pensait que
le fait d'avoir un parti central avec
deux forces extrêmes c'est un leur en
démocratie il y a toujours eu la droite
et la gauche depuis 200 depuis 25
longtemps même si le contenu a évolué
idéologiquement on a eu au départ une
gauche qui était républicaine en dans
les au 18e siècle avec face à une droite
plutôt monarchique plutôt
bonapartiste et puis cette se débat
entre la gauche et la droite a évoluer
on a eu le débat sur l'école publique la
laïcité dans la charnière du 19e et du
20e et puis après sur le libéralisme et
l'intervention de l'État dans dans
l'économie donc dire que il y a plus de
clivage gauche-droite Emmanuel Macron a
orchestré est un leur derrière cela le
macronisme s'éteindra avec
malheureusement le deuxième mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron puisqu'il n'y a pas de
socle idéologique il n'y a pas de socle
idéologique chez vous d'ailleurs vous le
réclamez souvent moi je suis socialiste
vous dites pas je suis macroniste je
suis socialiste je suis de gauche oui et
oui je suis donc je le Macron la gauche
il met des gens de droite et des gens de
gauche et même des communes
là vous parlez du très longtemps ouais
voilà et en plus je rigole il est parti
pendant longtemps et en plus on était
quand même à la sortie d'une seconde
guerre mondiale qu'on aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans dans ce climat là ça
c'est le premier pas pardon on est
aujourd'hui dans une guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui laquelle gare économique
mondiale on l'est comme attendez
il est pas là le débat il est pas entre
la droite et la gauche il est entre ceux
qui croient encore à la France et à sa
capacité de faire face aux différents
problèmes
politiques ce n'est pas l'Europe qui va
nous apporter le salut alors que changer
de débat et de faire tout contre Macron
non mais si si je me tiens hier Emmanuel
Macron c'est celui des Français les
mêmes les mêmes oui mais ce sont les
mêmes ce sont les mêmes regarder les
enquêtes qui ne souhaitaient pas sa
réélection à une très large majorité et
dans les dernières enquêtes hier le
représentant d'ibsos mais le confirmer
mais la majorité elle s'exprime il faut
mais oui ils ont considérés quand vous
interrogez qui était capable de tenir le
cap et de mener le pays par le
redressement c'était lui voilà ce que
les Français ont considérés hier soir je
prends des Français dans leur ensemble
je parle des Français dans leur ensemble
quand ils sont interrogés ils ne
souhaitaient pas la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron et une partie à voter
pour lui celle qui est venue voter et
dans les courriers d'ailleurs il
souhaite plus de 66% soit une
cohabitation exactement c'est quand même
Emmanuel Macron lui-même François
Patriat dès les premiers mots de son
discours il s'est il a dit je sais que
nombre de compatriotes ont voté pour moi
non par adhésion à mes idées mais pour
faire barrage à Marine Le Pen quelle
réponse vous allez le rapporter avec
vous il y a deux il y a des gens qui
sont pas aller voter des gens qui ont
voté contre il y a des gens qu'on voté
pour lui et qu'ils ne partagent pas les
idées ou le programme d'Emmanuel Macron
je les en remercie parce que ils ont
proposé aujourd'hui un vrai soulagement
puisqu'ils nous ont évité le pire ils
nous ont évité le pire je le pense
ensuite pour ce qui me concerne moi j'ai
choisi celui que je pense être le
meilleur pour gouverner pour gouverner
le pays donc dans ce domaine j'entends
bien et d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit le prénom
hier soir il faut entendre tout le monde
il faut prendre en compte les désespoir
les colères les rancœurs les
ressentiments les divisions il faut les
prendre en compte c'est le rôle d'un
chef de l'État de rassembler et au
moment où chef d'État au moment où le
chef d'État cherche à rassembler ce
matin vous cherchez tous à diviser moi
je voudrais bien je veux bien mais on
est d'accord mais ça les Français
l'entendre aussi si vous savez les
prédictions sur ce que veulent les
Français les Français ne voulaient pas
un débat entre Marine Le Pen et puis
Emmanuel Macron ils l'ont ils ont voté
alors pas voulu pourquoi est-ce qu'on y
est arrivé expliquez-moi
une excellente campagne parce que Marine
Le Pen a fait une séance elle était la
seule depuis 6 mois à aller au contact
des Français elle leur a parlé elle leur
a dit ce qu'elle souhaitait pour le pays
elle a tenu compte des propositions
d'Emmanuel Macron qui ont ensuite évolué
pour éviter leur a dit ou le rejoindre
les Russes que ça veut dire ça elle a
dit simplement et ça c'est rigoliste
vous avez fait référence au général de
Gaulle je suis moi-même gaulliste et
vous avez fait référence en France en ce
moment
il y a une attitude qu'il est et qui ne
l'est pas en dialogue au niveau
international pas avec les personnes on
dialogue avec les les pays donc elle a
dit que il faudra demain tenir compte de
la Russie personne ne peut dire le
contraire et qui sera le dirigeant de la
Russie
dans deux mois six mois vous ne savez
pas les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui mais mais
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé dans
toute l'histoire des relations
internationales et en tout cas tels que
les concevaient le général de Gaulle
vous n'aurez jamais eu de relation avec
la Chine avec le président de Nixon si
on avait eu le raisonnement que vous
tenez et on va revenir à ce qu'a dit
Emmanuel Macron hier sur ces Français
auxquels il s'est adressé qui ont voté
pour lui non par conviction mais pour
faire barrage à Marine Le Pen Emmanuel
Macron en promis des réponses à cette
colère il a promis une nouvelle méthode
qu'est-ce que vous attendez ce matin
Alexis Corbière de la part du président
de la République mais moi je suis pas
naïf ces nouvelles méthodes évidemment
ça va être mieux demain c'est formidable
il a entendu la bienveillance je peux
vous faire aussi la liste de tout le
champ lexical bon très bien maintenant
bon je pense que les gens il s'agit sont
il faut sortir de là pour avancer très
concrètement y compris je m'adresse une
fois de suite pardon à François Patriat
pour ou contre la retraite à 65 ans
c'est très concret pour ou contre la
retraite à 65 ans qu'on fait travailler
les Français plus et plus longtemps
c'est ce qu'il a dit sous les
applaudissements de vos supporters à
l'Arena moi je suis pas d'accord mais
les Français ont le droit d'être
d'accord s'ils veulent travailler plus
longtemps votez pour vous mais si c'est
pas le cas il y a Mélenchon et la
retraite à 60 ans on va on peut
continuer les thèmes comme ça sortons
parce que le et en même temps est une
manière aussi parfois de ne rien dire ou
de ne rien faire et ouais ou de faire
des choses que je désapprouve baisser
l'assurance chômage de près de 4
millions de chômeurs qui concerne quand
même beaucoup de gens je suis en radical
des accords baissé de 5 euros les appels
pour les gens les plus modestes je suis
en radical d'accord et je peux continuer
la liste donc ce qu'il y a de formidable
parce que tous autour de cette table on
pense que toutes les tensions et des
accords que nous avons il faut les
tranchées démocratiquement moi je pense
que ce pays peut partir et se déchirer
sauf si on arrive à créer des conditions
que les élections tranchent au nombre de
sujets moi je pensais mon analyse vous
avez le droit d'être en accord avec moi
que les tensions sociales qui avaient ce
pays ne sont pas apaisés par le résultat
d'élection présidentielle je l'assume
devant leur représentant du
rassemblement national je ne souhaitais
pas votre victoire je souhaitais votre
défaite parce qu'il comprit ce que vous
avez exprimé clairement à travers votre
candidate qui consiste à dire que une
religion dans ce pays il n'y aurait il y
aurait une interdiction de signes
religieux dans la rue et contrairement à
la loi de 1905 elle a jamais dit ça
elle a dit qu'elle était contre le voile
dans la rue vous allez dans des
quartiers comme la Seine-Saint-Denis par
exemple
et qu'est-ce qui se passe là-bas vous
voyez des burqa vous envoyez pas vous
voyez monsieur alors si vous faites pas
la différence entre la burqa mais je le
vois je veux dire par là qu'on a une loi
dans la rue c'est pareil la burqaï de
quoi
c'est la même chose bien sûr d'accord
interdiction votre candidat a proposé
l'interdiction du voile dans la rue du
voile comme signe de l'islamisme pas de
l'islam vous réalisez ce que vous disiez
mais c'est exactement ce qu'on veut il y
a une religion moi je mon opinion
personnelle n'importe quoi moi vous
savez j'ai pas un attachement religion
en soi mais je pense que la liberté
publique c'est que dans la rue mais je
pense pas des fonctionnaires on a le
droit de mettre une petite part on a le
droit éventuellement de mettre en voile
quelque soit mon opinion et vous vous
voyez dès que je discute avec vous mais
en restant là parce qu'on est on est
d'accord assumons-le vous ne parlez de
burqave mélangez
la loi républicaine n'est pas appliquée
à l'heure actuelle c'est la loi de 1905
et un interdit pas non mais ne me faites
pas la leçon parce que vous m'inquiétez
la loi 1905 elle est très claire c'est
une loi c'est une loi de liberté de
conscience et de liberté religieuse et
aucune aucun article de la 905 qui
définit la laïcité n'interdit ainsi une
religieux dans la rue pourquoi des pays
qui ont la religion vous avez la France
il est imposé à une large partie de des
personnes qui le portent il n'est pas
souhaité n'y voulait pas monsieur
c'est intéressant juste que je vous
disiez si c'est intéressant juste que
vous disiez
mais justement juste un chiffre
puisqu'on a posé notre partenaire et
psau soit passé à poser la question
française sur est-ce que c'est Emmanuel
Macron est réélu il y aura des troubles
et des tensions dans le pays 77% des
Français ont dit oui parce que voilà
parce que je veux dire il y a 8 ans 9
millions de gens sous le seuil de
pauvreté bref ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut profitons de l'occasion on a
une élection au mois de juin si les
dates ne bougent pas on va avoir deux
mois de discussion cette fois-ci il y
aura pas cette histoire de candidats pas
candidat etc tranquillement nous je
répète ce que je disais tout à l'heure
moi je parle pour moi je comprends que
les gens t'ont à table aussi défendre
leurs opinions et c'est tout à fait
respectable nous on va élargir ce qu'on
appelle l'Union Populaire on va créer
des conditions je ne sais pas si nos
amis ou les gens à qui au sens adresser
à qui nous sont adresser vont répondre
favorland mais je le veux ardemment pour
qu'on élargissant on va essayer d'avoir
un programme social qui reste dans les
pures de ce que nous avons présenté aux
Français que dont je viens de parler
tout à l'heure et qui va permettre
peut-être que les 12 millions de gens
qui sont abstenus vont se dire là cette
fois-ci il y a l'occasion de changer des
choses et on y va pour gagner parce que
je pense que ce président minoritaire
peut être aussi minoritaire dans
l'Assemblée nationale et nous pouvons
faire une majorité populaire autour de
nos thèmes ça vaut le coup donc je dis à
tous ceux qui sont mobilisés notamment
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les autres
remobilisez-vous ne perdez pas de vue
clinique son présidentielle peut-être
qu'elle occupe l'espace et les élections
au mois de juin elles sont aussi
importantes voire plus donc restez
mobilisé intéressez-vous au débat
écoutez tous les candidats restez restez
comment dirais-je politiser
républicain quoi parce qu'on a envie que
ce pays aille mieux donc pour vous c'est
c'est un véritable 3e tour ben oui voilà
vous en avez déjà une vingtaine de pour
cent qui ne vous ont pas suivi
ils n'ont pas suivi les consignes de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier
on est en France je vous le rappelle
donc vous n'avez pas la capacité de
réunir
vous chercherez mais vous ne pouvez pas
parce que vous êtes discrédité pour le
faire parce que effectivement vous avez
contribué à ce que la retraite à 65 ans
soit mise en application je me tourne
dans deux sénateurs
ça fait deux fois ça fait deux fois que
le faire valoir et l'assurance
il gagne tout le temps il est détesté
mais face à vous il gagne parce que
effectivement les gens ne vous
supportent pas non plus c'est pas un
problème
législatives il y a un enseignement déjà
Emmanuel Macron père des millions de
voix entre 2017 et 2000 et 2021
il faut comparer le second tour si on
commence à mélanger le premier second
tour on s'en sort plus en 5 ans hyper le
nombre d'électeurs a augmenté voilà il
perd 2 millions de voix alors que Madame
Lefebvre on gagne 3 donc c'est quand
même assez alarmant mais le message qui
a été porté aussi par les électeurs hier
en tout cas c'est comme ça je l'analyse
c'est que Marine Le Pen n'a pas la
capacité à gouverner je pense que c'est
un enseignement ça fait trois fois
qu'elle se présente à l'élection
présidentielle et trois fois quel
qu'elle perd donc ça c'est un signal
très fort maintenant là où je rejoins
lexicorbières c'est qu'on a des
législatives qui sont là pour poser le
débat démocratique pour vraiment avoir
un projet de société et c'est pour ça
que j'appelle l'ensemble des électeurs
de droite à revenir vers les parties
traditionnelles à revenir vers les
républicains pour qu'on puisse porter un
projet de société qu'on puisse débattre
avec
force de gauche avec l'extrême gauche
avec l'extrême droite sur ce projet là
parce que ce débat là encore une fois il
n'a pas eu lieu dans le cadre de
l'élection présidentielle quand Emmanuel
Macron rentre en campagne c'est 15 jours
de campagne il fait deux discours jamais
jamais on la questionné sur son bilan
oui le bilan du quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron l'inventaire de ce quinquennat
n'a pas été fait alors on a eu un
problème d'incarnation on a eu un
problème mais nous on a fait notre auto
critique on va faire notre auto
quitteration pour la fonction
présidentielle par rapport à Valérie
Pécresse on a aussi un problème de
politique c'était pas un problème de
ligne politique c'était pas un problème
de faiblesse des républicains je
continue on a légitime on a je vais y
venir on a aussi un problème de ligne
politique qu'il faudra trancher il faut
qu'on révise notre notre socle
idéologique avec des idées beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus innovantes et puis
derrière
la question du leadership effectivement
est-ce que notre partie est là et dans
son ADN et là pour faire des primaires
pour faire des congrès pour avoir une
sélection ou est-ce que le leadership
doit être beaucoup plus naturel
c'est-à-dire que la personne qui prend
le parti et le candidat naturel
laissez-moi finir et le candidat naturel
pour l'élection présidentielle toutes
ces questions là on va se les poser
après législatives mais pour le mais
avant qu'est-ce que vous faites les
législatives doivent se faire sur quelle
ligne pour vous Stéphano est-ce que les
républicains doivent marquer leurs
différences et présenter des étiquettes
des candidats sous l'étiquette des
républicains où est-ce qu'il faut des
accords avec les Macron avec le
panoramique la troisième force et le
score de Valérie Pécresse n'est pas
l'image et le score des républicains
dans le paysage national que ça soit
l'ensemble au niveau de l'ensemble des
élections locales ou nationales donc on
représente une troisième force une
troisième voie on a une ligne politique
qu'il va falloir trancher dès les
législatives mais derrière il y a il y a
un sujet sur la reconstruction c'est la
recomposition de la droite et les
républicains ont toutes leurs parts
56% des Français souhaite qu'Emmanuel
Macron perdent les législatives ça vous
alarme ça il y avait un chiffre il y a
15 jours qui disait que Madame Le Pen
allait faire 49 % et puis il y a un
chiffre il y a 4 mois qui disait que
Madame Pécresse elle est bête Emmanuel
Macron et puis et puis il y a des gens à
côté
63% des Français voulaient pas se dire
vacciner alors moi je veux bien que vous
aimiez retrouver de la dramaturgie vous
avez besoin de dramaturgie parce
qu'autrement ça marche pas le débat bon
alors j'entends bien il faudra matiser
faut dire les Français les Français vont
dire qu'il y aura des problèmes sociaux
j'ai tellement entendu dire tous les ans
depuis je fais la vie politique et il y
a longtemps malheureusement et bien que
l'été serait chaud que le printemps se
réchaud que que l'automne se réchauffe
une majorité française ça c'est pas
seulement le sondage c'est des urnes
il y a 48 millions d'électeurs et vous
faites 10 18 millions de voix Alexis
écoute-moi je ne veux pas entendre dire
président minoritaire le président a été
élu c'est une interprétation des
résultats que tu fais le président a été
élu hier avec 58 plus 58% des voix il
n'est pas minoritaire il n'est pas
minoritaire dans ce pays je vous ai dit
on est démocratie il pourrait y avoir
que 50 ou 60% des élections aux
États-Unis aux États-Unis il y a 50% des
lecteurs soit personne si vous me
permettez cette familiarité parce qu'on
se parle honnêtement au-delà de nos
désaccord et écoute-moi François
au-delà de nos désaccords j'entends bien
Emmanuel Macron va exercer la fonction
présidentielle maintenant je dis et je
sais qu'au fond de vous pardon j'aime
pas cet argument mais vous le savez ce
pays qui est dans un état de grande
tension n'est pas apaisé par l'élection
écoutez moi écouter moi quand il y a
48,7 millions d'électeurs et qu'au terme
de cette élection face à Madame Le Pen
et que toute une série de gens qui me
sont proches et j'en dirai pas plus mais
on m'aime voté pour Monsieur Macron en
étant radical des accords avec lui qu'à
l'arrivée tout ça fait au mieux 18 et
quelques millions de voix comme le
disait notre ce que tu veux dire
je veux dire je ne dis pas le mot
attendez attendez je vais je vais vous
répondre franchement
il est légitime reviendra dire que
j'appelle la manifester actuellement
devant l'Élysée pour l'interdire non
c'est pas ça que je dis il était élu
démocratiquement c'est lui le Président
je conteste pas mais je dis quand on a
l'esprit républicain et vous l'avez
comme moi que
de la souveraineté populaire ne se
retrouve pas majoritairement me
semble-t-il sur ce président et
d'ailleurs même cette cinquième
république qui concentre autant de
pouvoir sur un homme qui ne repente
qu'un tiers des électeurs ça n'est pas
sain c'est ça que je dis et je l'avais
dit à François Bayrou en 2017 qui était
heureux de cette victoire je dis et
regardez le pays si vous vous plastronez
je l'ai entendu pardon encore hier soir
la part madame borne qui dit les
Français adhèrent à notre projet non
mille fois non comprenez-le et si vous
êtes obstiné là-dessus pas vous parce
que vous vous êtes vous avez une
habileté mais il y a une brutalité
parfois dans le macronyme qui consiste à
croire que les gens lui donnent mandat
pour faire la retraite à 65 ans ce pays
ira dans le mur il va se casser il va se
déchirer les gens vont dire que les
élections ne servent à rien il y aura
même la tentation autoritaire qu'il
emportera à la fin et l'extrême droite
progressera parce que vous êtes le
carburant de l'extrême droite c'est vous
qui les faites monter alors
tout ce discours qui bon je vous entends
Alexis je respecte ce que tu dis j'ai
pas de lunettes je respecte mais
j'essaie de dire une chose les Français
est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui qui
sera capable de donner une majorité à un
président qui a été un rempart contre
l'extrême droite qui a fait en sorte de
rassembler le maximum
je les insultes pas mais qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire non mais c'est
un qualificatif qui a été employé
pendant tous les 15 jours c'est ça qui
dit que je dis je dis je dis simplement
que je pense que cette victoire
d'aujourd'hui je la prends certes les
bonheur mais je prends aussi comme un
soulagement je la prends comme un
soulagement parce que nous avons évité
l'extrême droite et le je vous le dis
deuxième chose est-ce que vous pendant
parlons de l'avenir est-ce que vous
pensez demain que les Français
pourraient faire confiance à des partis
de droite comme de gauche qui sont
explosés divisées la droite est divisée
dans ses propres courants en deux ou
trois courants l'extrême droite est
divisée il y a monsieur Zemmour il y a
Madame Le Pen la gauche et ultravisée
comment est-ce que comme est-ce que vous
pensez demain franchement que pour
conduire le réforme de ce pays on a
besoin d'un rabibochage de 53 jours de
campagne pour gouverner le pays demain
est-ce que vous pensez demain qu'il
aurait en marche avec vous
combien faisait d'abord
j'ai subi aux élections intermédiaires
des sarcasmes déricalement vous avez vu
la République en marche et le Fillon
100% je l'ai tout entendu je l'ai
accepté comme je n'ai pas et je n'ai pas
à ce moment-là je fais ce que tu as
changé
cette fois-ci je ne m'adresse pas à vous
manque de l'opposition comme vous êtes
adresser à nous lors des municipales
de partout aujourd'hui moi je ne raille
personne je respecte tout le monde et le
président respecte tout le monde et ce
qu'il entend c'est pas divise et
continue à diviser les gens ou à
chercher une inhibition à travers
l'élection mère c'est l'élection dans ce
pays le général de Gaulle l'avait voulu
c'est l'élection présidentielle il n'y a
pas de troisième tour il n'y a pas de 3e
tour à la poussière ça vous vous
souvenez ce que disait général de Gaulle
des Français vous vous souvenez bon très
bien alors bon écoutez bien je pourrais
pas vous le rappeler ce matin mais le
Président je crois qu'il y a un problème
il y a un problème de gravité de
cohérence et d'efficacité et moi je suis
convaincu que le chef de l'État aura la
majorité au législatives voilà juste
c'est à dire que vous n'êtes pas prêt ce
matin à attendre la main alors que le
rassemblement national a fait un score
historique vous n'êtes pas de vous
n'êtes pas prêt à attendre la main à
droite attend de la main à gauche pour
vous la majorité ça doit être une
majorité seulement macroniste
pas aujourd'hui une majorité macroniste
aujourd'hui quand je vois agir quand je
vois horizon quand je vois le quand tu
vois des gens qui nous ont rejoint ça
c'est proche de Manuel Macron il ne soit
pas macroniste que je sache aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi j'aspire un grand
mouvement et dans lesquels dans lequel
viendra le centrisme dans lequel viendra
dans lequel vous pouvez vous pouvez
toujours rêver citez-moi un philosophe
centriste vous m'avez déjà dit ça il y a
15 jours mais oui non ça n'existe vous
pouvez toujours rêver du vieux bon
combat gauche-droite ça existe 250 ans
stérile moi je souhaite du président un
rassemblement des Français un
rassemblement des Français
d'abstentionner ils veulent nous
rejoindre demain là je crois que le
Président hier soir l'a dit clairement
et nous lisons clairement tous ceux qui
veulent nous rejoindre pour participer
aux responsabilités pour partager pour
partager demain la vision du président
et faire avancer c'est quoi le socle
idéologique c'est quoi le macronisme
qu'est-ce que le macronisme quelle est
la si je vous demande c'est quoi le
gaulliste vous diriez la même chose je
peux vous dire le macronisme
c'était quoi c'est aujourd'hui c'est la
croissance le travail la religion la
redistribution la protection la
souveraineté voilà c'est parti
d'ailleurs par Marine Le Pen mais je
suis avec succès avec succès
Emmanuel Macron présente aussi un danger
non pendant les 5 ans qui ont précédé il
a souvent une insulte
je parle des cinq ans à venir oui il est
élu mais il n'est pas soumis à
réélection il n'a pas cette perspective
de sanction depuis 2017 il n'a pensé
qu'à 2022 c'est ça qui s'est passé
pendant 5 ans il a fait de
l'électoralisme à propos de la crise
sanitaire il en faisait aussi à propos
de la crise ukrainienne tous les
Français l'ont vu en faisant de
l'électoralisme et donc sans avoir de
perspective de pas du tout moi pas du
tout pas du tout je vous dis simplement
vous savez l'exercice du pouvoir vous
savez la façon dont on était traité
parfois les parlementaires de sa propre
majorité vous savez la façon dont il a
décidé seul d'un certain nombre de
choses un seul avec l'aide du cabinet de
conseils par exemple c'est votre
institution qu'il a très bien dit dans
un rapport je veux parler de l'affaire
McKinsey et donc 5 ans sans avoir de
sanctions attendues du peuple français
du comportement d'Emmanuel Macron peut
présenter pas du tout il commence à du
tout et ben parce que
c'était le septennat et il n'y avait pas
de limite à la réélection
mais j'ai du mal à comprendre ils ont
été soumis à la réélection il y a eu les
périodes de cohabitation en s'agissant
du Jacques Chirac mais messager sur du
président Pompidou son mandat a été
interrompu sinon il aurait écouté
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
vous ne souhaitez que le chaos demain
vous présentez pas du tout pas du tout
le système électoral ne permet pas la
représentation du peuple français dans
son ensemble vous allez vous aviez déjà
descend en 2017 vous ne l'avez pas fait
si vous le dites si vous le faites ça ne
sera pas avant 2027 donc ne trompez pas
les Français avec cette affaire moi je
dis aux Français si vous voulez être
présenté puisque vous avez été un grand
nombre à ne pas voter pour Emmanuel
Macron que vous ayez absorptionné pour
Emmanuel Macron à Stéphanie
nationale à comprendre monsieur Patriat
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé un programme
d'économie de 10 milliards à 14
milliards sur les collectivités
dans son projet présidentiel écouter
10 milliards à 14 milliards de 10
milliards il a dit qu'il y aurait de il
y aurait des ergonomies sur les
collectivités territoriales alors on
peut jouer Sarkozy on peut jouer on peut
jouer avec les mots vous êtes
représentants des collectivités territ
bien le Sénat vous aussi bien sûr c'est
pour ça que je suis con
monsieur Macron parce que qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire monsieur Macron ce qui va
encore taper dans les caisses des
collectivités des communes non vous
n'avez pas lu et équilibré le budget de
l'État ce qui est une vraiment un point
de désaccord entre nous le deuxième
aspect attention
patria parce que sinon on va pas y
arriver
aucune dotation n'a baissé en France
pendant 5 ans c'est faux c'est faux
pour jouer avec les mots la dotation
globale de fonctionnement oui justement
ils le savent bien oui effectivement je
vais faire 20 milliards d'économies 20
milliards pour l'État et 20 millions
pour les qualités non pas c'est 20
milliards maintenant
j'étais à 10 à 14 milliards maintenant
c'est 20
milliards pour l'État d'accord
juste revenir sur la proportionnelle on
agite ce chiffon en disant proportionnel
proportionnelle attention quand on
touche à nos institutions à ne pas
retomber à ne pas retomber dans les
écueils de la Quatrième République la
proportionnelle a été un marqueur très
fort de la Quatrième République et il y
a eu une instabilité derrière de
gouvernement lié à cette proportion
fait la sécurité sociale faut arrêter ce
discours la Quatrième République a été
formidable et elle permettait autre
chose que cette monarchie ont changé
le gouvernement parfois toutes les
semaines alors actuellement tous les
compétences de liste de tous les
ministres des finances sont succédé du
fait qu'on a Monsieur Castex qui était
un inconnu qui devait en premier
ministre Édouard Philippe qui avait
soutenu non mais très attention non mais
je vous dis besoin on a compris le
désaccord que j'avais que le RN mais moi
je ne suis pas d'accord monsieur aucune
force au second tour soit quasiment
inexistante à l'Assemblée
nationale je suis d'accord je dis
attention à la proportionnelle intégrale
c'était la base de la 4e République on a
vu ce que ça a donné pouvoir des députés
parce que le problème c'est pas ça
proportionnelle si on a encore un
président qui peut dissoudre un
président et en gouvernement qui a qui
fait l'initiative des lois et cetera je
veux dire moi après 5 ans de mandat de
députés je veux dire c'est un parlement
qui est assez croupion assagi oui mais
c'est le fond du problème l'utilisation
du pouvoir des institutions mais ce sont
des ordonnances non mais les ordonnances
vous le savez très bien moi je crois que
jamais autant d'ordonnance
sous ce cadre même il y en a même qui
ont été prises entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle contrairement
à toutes les traditions
moi je pense que y compris là-dessus
quand il y a autant d'abstention on l'a
vu on a parlé on a évoqué la sélection
intermédiaire 30% de participation pour
désigner président de région tout à
l'heure vous me demandez ce qui est
légitime les mots je veux pas mais je
pense comme président de région qui
était lui avec 10 à 15% du corps
électoral il y a un problème voilà et
idem pour un merde donc donc comment on
fait pour embrasser tout ça comment on
fait pour que le citoyen est plus de
pouvoir je reprends pas ce que et
pourtant on est dans la proportionnelle
au niveau des régions oui oui non mais
comme quoi oui mais donc il faut
réfléchir à c'est pour ça que nous on a
porté la 6e république comment il y a un
contrôle un droit de regarder citoyens
de possibilités d'intervention avec des
référents administratif citoyen nombre
de sujets moi je voulais juste et c'est
normal on met de la passion dans tout ça
soyons précis pardon je reviens ce que
je disais tout à l'heure là on doit
trancher pour ou contre retraite à 65
ans voilà très clairement si je dois
résumer des choses
mais parce que sinon on va se perdre
droit de gauche machin François patriar
avec la bilté l'intelligence qui est la
sienne et je le dis vraiment va nous
dire non mais il faut rassembler faut
travailler on sait plus trop on parle on
sait plus de quoi on parle moi je dis
pour ou contre
est-ce qu'on augmente le SMIC est-ce que
vraiment aujourd'hui on revient sur ce
que je disais tout à l'heure la baisse
de l'assurance chômage qui a affecté
beaucoup de gens est-ce que on revient
sur le RSA doit pas être conditionné à à
20 à 22h de boulot et cetera ce qu'on
défend aussi qu'est-ce qu'on crée des
postes d'enseignants est-ce que cetera
il faut qu'on parle clairement ce qui se
conçoit bien s'énonce clairement
l'habileté de certains ou peut-être la
guerre Ukraine tout ce que vous voulez
font que bien sûr des sujets ont été
pris de manière un peu confuse si on a
cette qualité de débat démocratique dans
le mois de mai dans le mois de juin qui
mobilise des gens qui leur montre qu'il
y a un enjeu dans ces élections souvent
jusqu'à présent et je voudrais terminer
là-dessus en raison du quinquennat et de
la proximité des élections législatives
c'était un peu la continuité un
président est élu on va lui on va donner
sa chance aux produits comme dirait un
commerçants et là je pense que ça n'est
pas le cas y compris prenez le
positivement cher François patriar je
pense qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est plus dans
la même situation que 2017 les gens
savaient pu citer du poil ou des plumes
ils savaient pas essayer de trouver de
gauche désormais ils savent ce que le
macronisme et je pense que il l'aurait
élu
on se retrouve au mois d'août sur les
élections
Alexis Corbière ce qu'il faut
véritablement poser le débat
démocratique mais je pense que aussi les
Français ont besoin de proximité de
disponibilités on a au niveau des
républicains la chance d'avoir un
ancrage local très très fort ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la République en
marche et je pense que c'est bien
d'avoir des des députés qui ont les
pieds sur terre qui ne sont pas hors-sol
puisqu'on l'a reproché très souvent à la
majorité présidentielle depuis 5 ans et
ce besoin d'écoute de proximité pour
répondre justement aux préoccupations
quotidiennes ce sera vraiment le le fil
conducteur je pense des législatives en
tout cas chez les réponses
parce que Eric Zemmour vous a attendu la
main hier soir on a l'impression que
vous vous la rejetez un peu cette pas du
tout il parle d'union des droites et
demander à Stéphane Le rugelier ce qu'il
pense de l'Union des droites et puis
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est de
savoir si à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons ou non une représentant une
représentation du peuple français hier
un espoir c'est levé pour au moins 41,5%
des Français qui malgré la nattem malgré
les qualificatifs d'extrême droite à
voter pour Marine Le Pen il faut que
cette partie du peuple français soit
représentée à l'Assemblée nationale il y
aura des candidats ils seront pas tous
du rassemblement national je ne suis pas
rassemblement national il y a un certain
nombre de mouvements qui sont autour de
Marine Le Pen il se présenteront
à l'Assemblée pendant tout le débat sur
la retraite jamais présent nous permet
une seule intervention Parlement
européen je sais aussi
devenait à l'Assemblée il ne faisait pas
et quand les Français
regardent les questions d'actualité il
voit du monde parce que là il y a les
télévisions mais ici regarde le débat
sur des projets de loi en général de la
nuit
et l'élection législative
bien entendu c'est d'ailleurs regardez
je vous en félicite mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il faut une représentation
à l'Assemblée nationale qui malgré le
mode de scrutin unique permettent à des
Français
et juste fan de ruguier vous avez été
clair sur l'union des droites pour vous
c'est loin absolument d'abord j'entends
parler
je suis sénateur il me semble pas que
j'ai ça hors sol je suis élu depuis 40
ans tout le temps donc il y a les
députés je salue le travail comme les
députés en marche ils ont fait un
travail de présence parce que le mandat
unique maintenant c'est qu'ils sont très
présentes qui ont travaillé que l'ombre
de loi votées qui sont des lois de
proximité hauteur d'hommes ont été le
four je ne partage pas votre analyse
maintenant l'objectif ce qui compte
maintenant c'est qu'effectivement on
engage le débat pour les législatives
tout petit peu de répit on va y aller ce
que je souhaite je le dis c'est qu'il y
a une cohérence et que le président et
les besoins moyens de mener sa politique
et pour ce faire s'agit pas de jeter des
amateurs parce que je vois pas
aujourd'hui dans le système actuel
puisque vous avez autant de voix ce qui
vous empêche d'avoir des députés
qu'est-ce qui vous en empêche rien
rien vous empêche si vous voudriez un
autre système pour être élu j'entends
bien et aujourd'hui pour vous le faites
donc ce que je crois ce que je pense
c'est que il faut demain qu'il y ait une
cohérence le président dit le
rassemblement le plus large le
dépassement l'élargissement que tous les
gens qui aujourd'hui disent voilà la
France va être face à des défis des
défis importants il va falloir avancer
retrouver de la souveraineté jusqu'à
commencer à faire le président va leur
faire demain et pour cela je pense qu'il
nous faudra une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'il obtiendra voilà et
merci messieurs merci pour ce débat et
on aura évidemment l'occasion de
redébattre de des législatives puisque
la campagne a été lancée dès hier soir
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]